you know I know it can be gratuitous
going after Newsome because he's so
obviously evil so you're saying you're
sitting there going Dave it's easy to do
that go after evil Gavin Newsom
could you do something could you go into
the archives could you find something
from when he was mayor that is proof
that he has an absolutely horrible track
record of Destruction
I can here's mayor Gavin Newsom San
Francisco mayor Gavin Newsom back in
2008 laying out his 10-year plan to end
homelessness
We Believe fundamentally that food
solves hunger that shelters soft sleep
and that housing solves homelessness and
if we're going to solve the problem of
those that are out on the streets that
we Define as homeless we better solve
the housing problem if we're going to
have an impact and that's why we
establish this framework what we call a
10-year plan to end chronicomas in San
Francisco
so to be clear that was 2008 it was a
10-year plan as you know it has gone
horrifically awry but it's sort of a
perfect version of what progressives do
with everything food solves hunger that
sounds pretty good put that on a bumper
sticker shelter solve sleep okay that's
kind of right at some level I suppose
housing solves homelessness
that all sort of sounds right but what
all what do you have to do with
progressives you just have to peel off
that little thin veneer of kind of sound
and good and seeming to be right and
then you realize these are just words
that they put together housing doesn't
solve homelessness homelessness usually
is related to bad economic conditions
and drug use and mental health and all
of those things just putting somebody in
a hotel room well now you've housed them
did you solve the problem no he
exacerbated all of these problems so he
literally destroyed San Francisco at one
time was one of the most beautiful
functional cities in America I remember
going to San Francisco for the first
time about 10 years ago and it was one
of the first cities that I had ever gone
to I mean this is this is hard to
believe that I I within an hour of being
there I was like I could move here I
would be happy here like there was
something actually great going on there
and of course the the proximity to
Silicon Valley and there was an economic
engine that was going great and there
was a sense of true tolerance in all of
these things and it has completely
bottomed out but don't take my word for
it we have videotape
foreign
there's tons of videos of that the point
of all of this is that when you have bad
policies when you just say the right
thing when that's completely
disconnected from reality you will
literally destroy your state and then
there will be other places that are
doing it right and then you will try to
destroy them Gavin Newsom is a bad bad
dude